well first things first y'all are
shutting down Hollywood Boulevard
tonight
yeah I'm from L.A born and raised so
anytime I'm here at Hollywood Boulevard
it reminds me of my childhood it feels
very surreal you know I was telling Dr
Dre LA's another character in this movie
it truly is it really is I think we were
excited to bring that energy that story
to this you know the previous films the
first one especially took place in
Philadelphia and I came to love that
City but this is my hometown so it's a
pleasure to honor it in the context of
these films you a coward bro and a fraud
crash but in half your life in the sale
watching somebody else live your life
store that little brother
I'm coming for it all so the film is not
only about to drop Michael just dropped
the Calvin Klein add-ons yes he did our
thoughts Tessa I you know some thoughts
you don't you can't talk about you know
some thoughts just exist there are more
feelings than thoughts
I stopped at like 14. I stopped I was
like just too many enough too much this
is the first film without Sylvester
Stallone in the Creed Legacy what do you
think the fans are gonna think when they
see this how they will appreciate I
really do feel like fly is so much a
part of the DNA of these films that I
think they'll feel his Spirit even
though he's not himself on screen
and do you see I think where this left
off I always think there's a lot of
story still to be told what do you think
I think it's the fans are excited to see
us we're excited to come back and return
to these characters we love playing them
foreign